ouais
[Musique]
quelle impolitesse ce début de vidéo à
la vôtre pour tous ceux qui regardent
des vidéos en buvant un truc je sais
qu'il se met à faire froid dehors alors
de plus en plus ça va avoir des trucs
chose dans la vidéo celui là l'est pour
vous sweety palme
écoutez ce soit aubry dit c'est l'enfer
sur terre d' accor lâche objet de vous
dire c'est absolument horrible ce n'est
que des trucs ou en les regardant on va
stresser on va avoir de l'empathie et du
coup on va stresser on va être inquiété
on va avoir un réflexe un peu un peu de
grands frères ou de grandes soeurs on va
être là genre je pourrais faire du
doublage pourrait doubler d animer je
sais je sais regardez ça colle
parfaitement à tous se sevrer dit ça a
commencé de tout ce qui me met mal et
mon goisses profondément d'accord et
vous savez que j'ai beaucoup d'angoissé
gens parlent seulement vous en faites
pas il n'y a pas de blessures padmore ya
rien de tout ça mais ça va vous faire
baver vous allez voir pourquoi par
exemple à ça assez vieux j'ai vu ça le
plus haut saut dans de l'eau sans
blessure tiens le gars est parfaitement
intact déjà les slips de bain faut que
ça revienne à la mode
parlons-en ça donne une classe
incroyable j'adore j'aimerais pouvoir
mettre un slip de bain sans que les gens
se moquent de moi bref regardez moi la
hauteur de ce nom mais c'est gm sans que
c'est fake mais qu il à combien de
mètres
il est beau m il a fait un brushing il
est tout beau pour ce très grand saut
[Musique]
zéro blessure alors vous le savez
certainement mais au cas où l'eau à
partir d'une certaine hauteur c'est
comme si tu tombé sur du bitume et la
hauteur dans laquelle il a sauté il s'y
fait un plat il est mort voilà y'a pas
de débat d'ailleurs je pense c'est
tellement dangereux qui a pas trop de
gens qui ont tenté depuis ou en tout cas
il n'avait pas ce slip de bain je suis
déçu une famille gorille qui checke un
photographe animalier
regardez moi cette énorme q si le
gorille s'énerve il est dead c'est aussi
simple que ça les gars si le gorille à
droite ses nervis des aides en tout cas
elle a la bonne attitude
il veut zéro souci il s'assoit derrière
lui regardez le il fait les pouilles
c'est trop mignon quel moment ça doit
être super l'humeur jo je suis content
pour les intérêts commencent à fini ça
se trouve il a mis son énorme q sur sa
tête et est décédé attention à lui à
droite quand il bouge il me il me
terrifie non envers les autres sont un
peu mignon genre si s'énerve tu sais
quoi là le potentiel cescom quand moi je
m'énerve c'est pas ouf celui à droite là
il a pas qu'un énorme qu il ad énormes
muscles pour faire attention il veut
juste vous dire bonjour il est tout
gentil
a tancé le gorille de la vidéo d'avancé
un chien là je comprends pas non mes
mecs c'est quoi ce mes mecs c'est un
chien qui fait 95 kg ça n'existe pas
c'est de la 3d et augmenter la taille du
chien
je ne conçois pas qu'un chien puisse
être si gros attends attends quoi mais
c'est dingue attend memex et mekouar
nemo cerveau ils ont dit on dirait qu'on
est dans un autre monde
on a découvert une planète sur laquelle
il ya de la vie est juste les chiens
font quatre fois la taille des chiffres
normaux sur terre c'est bizarre je ne
m'attendais pas à ça annoncer les trucs
de ses trucs de fête foraine mais level
max où ils sont très très bons c'est une
tyrolienne
[Applaudissements]
c'est une immense balançoire c'est
incroyable les amis il faut qu'on parle
j'aimerais trop être capable de faire
des trucs comme ça mais je ne peux pas
m'empêcher de douter sur le matériel
c'est plus fort que moi c'est mon esprit
il est trop rationnel j'ai trop peur des
risques alors qu'ils sont quasi nulles
mais chez ba du coup je suis très jaloux
j'adorerais pouvoir faire ça aux scellés
mais qu'est ce qu'elle a des glaciers
est bloqué qu'est ce qui se passe je
mets ce cas-là de rien donc je sais pas
[Musique]
ok il s'attache à la corde pendant qu'il
est en position de d'escaladé complexe
déjà en fait il ya quasi pas de glace et
de neige là sur le caillou qui est dans
la merde
[Musique]
ah ouais ouais
les gens qui font des sports extrêmes ce
qu'aime incroyablement n'en parle pas
des petits trucs là parce que j'ai
besoin d'en parler ça il ya des humains
ils sont tellement en manque
d'adrénaline que ils ont besoin d'aller
à 1000 mètres d'altitude sur de la glace
qui glisse et de frôler la mort pour
ressentir la même chose que ce que je
ressens quand juste je passe au rouge et
infos piétons tu vois c'était incroyable
c'est incroyable ouah ce levé du mauvais
pied n'est pas une option
alors ça c'est un sacré bail il ya des
gens qui font de l'escaladé qui font
démonter tellement longue qui sont
obligés de faire une pause pour dormir
et du coup il accroche au mur une plaque
pour voir dormir dessus un vrai comment
tu dois être bien en vrai de vrai si tu
oublies 2 si tu regardes partez
tranquille contre une paroi en pleine
ascension qu'elle kiffe je le ferai
jamais amour ce qui passe un peu trop
proche de nous
[Musique]
quelle bête c'est incroyable
waouh c'est beau et regardent ils
reviennent et la vidéo s'arrête
le capitaine a allumé la consigne de
sécurité
oh non pitié c'est pas mon cauchemar
mais oh la la
non mais qu'est ce qui lui arrive et ce
pauvre et acteur il ne demande qu'à
tomber de l'avion
il veut juste se décroche et je déteste
est assise au niveau de la halle parce
que je vois le réacteur et je suis
stressé tout le vol j'ai des coups
d'oeil aux réacteurs et à chaque fois je
me dis petit à petit et l'arrière je
regarde et il va bientôt voir l'acteur
yves haby tous les réacteurs vont bien
quoi y en a un sur 1 milliard qui va pas
bien mais quand tu tombes sur celui qui
va pas bien je pense vraiment je ferai
une énorme crise d'angoissé et que je
pourrais finir en arrêt cardiaque
je n'arriverai pas à être jeu j'y
arriverai pas aulas ça y est ça m'a
donné les mains moites c'est bon j'ai
compris le nom du crb dit une journée
typique au travail
il faut juste pas regarder en bas ils ne
prendraient aux jeunes c'est voilà je
pense la peur ça doit pas être la même
étonnamment je pense pas que quand tu es
dans l'espace tout a plus peur que quand
t'es juste en haut d'une plate-forme à
300 mètres du sol tu es tellement haut
c'est tellement beau en plus ya pas de
gravité tu dois je sais pas tu dois plus
rien comprendre je pense quand les
russes arrivent en australie oh oui bbbb
tiens je te caresse un peu le dos vient
avec moi j'adore voir des animaux genre
hyper dangereux traités comme des
animaux hyper mignon inoffensif ça me
tue de rien regardez moi il caresse un
alligator tranquille c'est incroyable
celle qu'ils honorent il est terrifié
ados attend c'est génial il est il fait
comme dans les dessins animés il fait
comme dans le dessin animé que
l'incroyable alors ceci dit j'ai fait de
la via ferrata avec douagbeu je me suis
liquéfiée m c'est exactement ça au
milieu des montagnes des câbles des
prises des 4 gambetta dans la pierre
auquel tu t'accroches pour risques à la
bêta une ceinture t'es accroché un fils
toujours ne peut pas tomber et jouets
des enfants de 7 ans 8 ans passés comme
ça qu'à être encore plus vite et était
au calme vous voulez pas jouer à dofus
comme tout le monde les enfants de 8 ans
[ __ ] fait j'y allais gosse là je râle
beaucoup en inde d'observation qui
s'incline à 45 degrés pour que tu es une
plus belle vue c'est des balades la sky
tree tower à tokyo donc c'est à tour la
plus haute de tous que quand j'étais
tout en haut
j'avais du mal à m'approcher des bidjan
vraiment j'avais peur de fou j'avais du
mal à me reprocher d'élite donc là ça
pardonnez moi mais je ne le fais jamais
oh là là c'est un cas c'est vraiment une
bonne idée un référent pour les gens
courageux
ça me tente mais pourquoi vous vous
infliger ça pourquoi aucun ramène au
beauf mérite de mourir
attends quoi annoncer un truc
d'ascenseur alors je veux pas vous créer
des angoisses 1 mais les escalators et
ascenseurs très dangereux
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de porte
y'a pas de porc dans l'ascenseur non mes
mecs à l'époque j'avais vu des vidéos
des vidéos d'un accident d'ascenseur
comme ça ou genre juste il par la porte
ouverte justement et les gens ils font
pas gaffe
depuis je me pose des petites questions
quand je prends l'ascenseur n'était pas
le cas avant et encore plus quand je
rentrais cna dessous j'ai tellement peur
à chaque fois que les portes elles se
ferment et que je la laisse avec moi
dedans et que le chien soit l'extérieur
horrible voilà tu voues partagent nos
angoisses
on a les mamans a tourné là pour ça un
faux pas et tu es non mais les trucs
d'altitude c'est bon on a compris
voilà maintenant vous arrêter on a
compris stop ok un ours polaire qui suit
un photographe
[Musique]
j'adore il est obligé de l'us open lors
ce mot là il veut totalement gras et ce
mec est un soyons honnête je me rends
compte qu'ils n'ont pas confiance en eux
les ours polaires est les ours polaires
réveillez vous les gars vous ressemblez
ça vous avez vous ressemblez pas à ça le
photographe luc robert toi mais gros tu
cours vers lui s'est terminée il ya même
pas débat les gars sont les sûr de votre
potentiel
attendez attendez attendez j'ai cru voir
un pont qui va pas du tout là oui c'est
bien ça oui un bec les gars mais ca mais
je vais les engueuler au jeu leur met
une claque
pourquoi il se met en danger comme ça
merde alors la bio pas sympa lui tous
ceux qui connaissent pas les escalades
j'ai pas vu la deuxième corde pendant
une seconde j'ai cru je gardais la vidéo
d'un mec qui était mort et dont on avait
retrouvé la gopro fait ce fait de ban et
le gard attention je vais parler d'un
truc que je maîtrise pas mais sachez que
la peur ça correspond à une certaine
certaines parties du cerveau qui est
active et chez certaines personnes cette
partie du cerveau est beaucoup moins
active voire pas du tout active
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ressentent très peu
la peur ou pas du tout du coup j'ai pas
mal de gens qui font des sports très
extrêmes qui ont en fait ce truc là de
cette partie du cerveau qui est quasi
off ça leur permet de garder un vrai
sang froid de ouf dans des situations ou
non serait tétanisé de peur que ce gars
là typiquement je peux pas faire ça
c'est impossible par contre est ce qui
fait tant par l'usure warzone je crois
pas non je suis nul un professeur a
démontré qu'un taureau n'attaque
personne s'il n'est pas provoqué hu
alors je j'y crois mais quand même je
vais pas la place de ces gens qu'on soit
honnête watts
regardez c'est un treuil a marqué le
trouble en fer est dedans ce n'est que
du tout petit trou dans laquelle il faut
se faufiler
regardez regardez la taille de ce trou
déjà juste pour rentrer et a déjà fait
un truc très petit regardez-moi ça
oh la la non mes mecs d'heathrow dibaba
olalalala matin en fait c'est fait pour
que tu luttes comme sa claustrophobie à
l'époque dans les catacombes itunes
j'avais dû passer un petit trou qui
était probablement plus grand que tous
les trous là dans le truc dans lequel le
mec et franchement j'avais stressé de
fou on était en vidéo et tout donc t'as
vu tu fais le mec mais j'étais pas bien
j'étais pas bien du tout âge et j'avais
cette image stop ne mourrai pas n'allait
pas plus profond plus de 300 plongeurs
et compris des professeurs de plongée
sont mortes dans des caves juste comme
celle ci la plongée c'est un game de
malades déjà juste faire le petit stage
de plongée là où tu descends à 12 mètres
je crois c'est impressionnant j'ai une
histoire de fou d'un plongeur je la
raconte répète en vidéo un jour j'ai une
histoire de dingues sur sa non venue mec
normal mais c'est dingue
en fait on voit pas mettez des petits
bouts de la peau de son douala qui
partagent à tous je vois pas ouah
attends j'ai rien compris c'est un
manège qui part en mode dans le vide
puis sas l'es1 mais c'est pas les
manèges sur les toits à las vegas
y'en a qu'on fait rôle à la mecque si
les freins lâchent
rolala à l'égard autant les manèges fait
souvent le mec et tout mais l'aja mais
je le fais d'orge par points qu'il
évident d'ailleurs soyons honnêtes c'est
pas pour rien du tout qui les vident le
sport le plus satisfaisant à garder
alors ça c'est clair mais très souvent
côté ce sport les gars c'est vraiment
trop mais à regarder je vous jure
oh là là là là mais quel courage et son
nom mêlé mostra pas croyable de faire ça
en fait je me demande comment tu fais
pour apprendre tu commences sûrement sur
des trucs ou moins haut mais 20 ya quand
même un moment où tu doit écarter les
jambes là comme un écureuil est épris
quoi c'est pas un ranger d'un parc
utilise son fusil à pompe pour séparer
de serre quoi
oh non leur boisson mêlée il va tirer
pour les séparer attendez attendez
attendez attendez que se passe-t-il quoi
il en a blessé au cap éditions home et
qu'elle est roux
c'était incroyable mais quel homme on
n'a pas les mêmes métiers les gars on
n'a vraiment pas le medicare
eh bien écoutez les amis c'est la fin de
cette vidéo j'ai beaucoup ont râlé mais
en même temps les gens me stresse je
comprends bien que ça les amuse mais moi
j'ai mon esprit rationnel qui me dit tu
n'es pas obligé de le faire et tu te
mets en danger même si la chance est
faible tu te mets en danger alors ne le
fait pas voilà j'espère que ce soit vrai
dit vous aura bien entendu vous pouvez
désormais lâchez vos accoudoirs que vous
venez de gratter avec vous ont plu tous
ces gens vont bien tout va pour le mieux
dans le meilleur des mondes mais je vais
faire ça tout je vais faire cette
oreille
[Musique]